welcome to ear biscuits the podcast for
two lifelong friends talk about life for
a long time i'm
rhett and i'm link this week at the
round table of dim
lighting we are talking about
changes yeah we changing your mind
we asked you uh where we ask these
questions which is twitter
at the on the mythical account uh to
tell us a time
that you change your perspective on
something could be small like a food
preference could be something big like a
major belief and why and boy we got a
lot of responses yeah i'm excited about
talking these but you know
yank in your laptop here so we can we
can look at some responses but
you know we wanted to talk about this
because
and kind of mission accomplished as far
as
i'm concerned here because we were
hoping that it would just be a
a refreshing sensation of people
sharing how they change their mind and
i don't know there's a humility
associated with saying i once
thought this and even if it's a minor
preference
but now i think this i i i disagree with
my former self about this thing big or
small
it it's something to celebrate in this
day and age when
people just dig in and there's there's
no conversations and
right not that this conversation is
going to get political yeah we didn't
necessarily i mean we we got some
light-hearted stuff and some
heavier stuff but it really doesn't get
into because we you know
uh we talk about those things in other
kinds well there's one thing that kind
of gets a little political in this but
anyway
one of the reasons i was so excited
about talking about this is all the
things that you just said
um but also i think that you know
there's a little bit of a selfish
a self-interest in this which is like
you know
in ways that we have shared on this
podcast we've changed our minds and i'm
kind of
fascinated with the reasons why people
change their mind
because i think a lot of times it's not
the reason that you state you know
and there's just all kinds of factors
and i think we got some really honest
honest uh responses and i'm just
fascinated with the concept
of perspective change and what leads to
it
and i like it like i said i just think
it's so timely because
it seems that there's so many people
spending
more of their energy attempting to
change
other people's minds in ways that we
haven't really seen before in like
discourse right
i was talking to jesse the other day and
i was like
you know she hates going on facebook uh
because
facebook has become a place where you
kind of just say this is who i am this
is what i believe
and then argue with people who differ
with you you know i think at first it
was kind of like hey
i'm having a baby and or
look at what i did with my friends and
then it would be like okay
maybe at once every four years during
the presidential election
people might start like saying what they
stood for or whatever
but now it's like a really high
percentage of the dialogue is just
people arguing with each other
but no one's actually moving on anything
like you said it's just people
continuing to
polarize and kind of uh
align themselves with other people who
all agree with them
and it's just there's no end in sight
right
it's discouraging yeah i mean so we're
making a choice to not celebrate people
who said
i changed someone else's mind yeah but i
ch
i changed my own mind and to see the
things that lead to people changing
their minds
and let me just say of all we've read
through almost
all the responses kiko definitely read
through all the responses
um none of them said
i used to think this and i changed my
mind because someone on facebook
argued with me that didn't happen in any
one of these
nobody said that right yeah so
so let's get into this i think that um
we could start with
elena at a later two five
five forty three sixty one two there's a
lot of those already taken
wow there's a lot of elaters out there
250
2 million 554 thousand nope
25 million it's 25 million is that a
phone number
we need can we put commas in your
username so she knows
paul see if she answers oh yeah is it
it's not a phone number no it's not it's
one two it's one
if you did one less digit we could
probably figure it out
yeah all right we're calling an audible
this episode is now
devoted entirely to trying to get in
touch with elena
uh she responded to us at mythical
i absolutely hate the sound of children
singing
so you thought we were gonna be start
all serious no we're not and
it's going to take us i don't know i
think this is serious to her she says
i used to love it but then all those
singing idol shows came out and now it's
like fingernails on a chalkboard
p.s i'm an elementary school teacher wow
so i wonder if it's the culture of
amateur
singing in general that maybe inspired a
change in the youth that then she
experienced personally
or is it just the idea of seeing so many
i mean how old you have to be to be you
got to be you got to be like 13 to be on
american idol yeah
i think what she means is that you know
she's surrounded by these
elementary school kids who are like
singing in chorus and stuff like that
and it's what what wasn't
necessarily uh pro
by any means or splendid but still
cute lost all of its luster
to the point that she actually said you
know what i don't like kid singing
anymore
oh i hate it i hate this sound ruined it
for me singing
television idol singing idol shows
ruined it for
but but she made a decision she's like
you know what
or sometimes you come to grips with how
you've changed and you just
and so that's kind of like a backdoor
decision right
well i don't like this anymore and i'm
okay with it so the decision is
owning it though it would be uh it
wouldn't make her life
easier being an elementary school
teacher if she would find a way to like
it
well she's not she's not the coral well
if she's
directly she didn't say that but if she
said i am an elementary school chorus
teacher yeah that would be tough maybe
we would be outing her right now first
of all
uh well she kind of outer herself on
twitter this makes me think of something
but it's not something you're supposed
to it's something you're supposed to
like so i do applaud her
and saying it is a preference but she's
standing by this is what i'm getting at
is
i actually recently
rediscovered how much i do like the
sound of children singing and this
sounds weird
i understand but let me just talk about
boy christmas boys choir situation i'm
talking about
moonrise kingdom which i watched
recently with the family watch
me and me and jesse and shepard watched
it and uh
i'm i'm beginning to really kind of
understand shepherd and
understand the kinds of things that he
will like and so
so i was like shepard i have a movie
that i want you to watch that i know you
were going to like of course this is wes
anderson's
moonrise kingdom um and right at the
beginning i could kind of look at him
and he was just seeing the way things
were unfolding and the way things were
being described and he just had this
little smile on his face
and then he just kept looking at me and
he was just like
i love this he was like this is the kind
of movie that i really like like he was
yeah and he wasn't just saying that
because i had planted the thought in his
mind
but anyway great movie it's a great
movie and i
i feel kind of bad about how much i
didn't
i loved it i really liked it when i
watched it in the theater
but i didn't realize that this might be
my favorite wes anderson movie
oh really like i i did it it wasn't in
like the top three for me
but i feel like it is now anyway lots of
boys choir you changed your mind about
it lots of boys choir
which i've always kind of liked the
sound of like a boys choir i've just
thought that it
got this sort of angelic sound to it
but like the way that he uses that music
in the movie there's a time and a place
it's so good it's just so good so i like
the sound of children singing
well you like the sound of professional
children yeah yeah right not amateurs
yeah yeah professional children
kaina is the name of the next respondent
at the real kaki
i've started drinking my coffee black
over the past couple of years
it's important to assert dominance over
beverages hashtag ear biscuits
wow there's a lot to unpack here kinda
um because i man
the way that i kind of interpret this is
i i totally relate with the idea
that there's something more respectable
and i'm not saying this is true i'm
saying i
have this perception that lives within
my mind that there's something more
respectable
about drinking coffee black that it's
ultimately better like if you had to
like
rank five people and there was a person
who put
a bunch of sugar and a bunch of cream in
their coffee on one end of the spectrum
and there was a person who drank their
coffee black on the other end of the
spectrum
i would respect the person who drank
their coffee black and i don't exactly
know
why that's the case it's more hardcore
it's like
it implies a toughness
because there's something to protect
yourself from when it comes to coffee
because coffee is a bit bitter yeah
anything
when you taste add cream or sugar to it
as you take a sip of your
cream laden coffee yeah we'll get to it
any sugar in there
no sugar but uh i'm a no sugar i'm a
butt cream man a butt cream man
i use butt cream as well but every
morning
every single morning you know what i'm
realizing this
when i i make my coffee
and it's and it's going down into my mug
and then i'm i go over to the
fridge and i reach for the half and half
i have a pang of guilt
to this day because and because of this
sentiment of it's
you know you're you're a you're a badass
if you can drink it black and here i am
you know it's like
it's like pouring defeat into my coffee
yeah and that's
okay i i have a theory about this i
think there's i think there's two things
going on right
so the legitimate side of the
migration from a lot of sugar and a lot
of cream in your coffee to black coffee
is a legitimate scientific
process that happens through with things
that are an acquired taste
right so it's like oh i don't really
like
alcohol oh but you know what i had a
wine cooler and no
now i now i drink just white wine
oh i'll drink just a white wine oh you
know what i tried a red i tried a pinot
noir
at this party and it was pretty good and
then you work your way up and the next
thing you know you're just putting back
like
20-year aged scotch you know what i'm
saying
that's a scientific process of your
literal face and mouth
adjusting to an acquired taste and i
think the same thing happens with coffee
so so there's a there's an achievement
right you know it's kind of like winning
it's just
that way it's almost like there's a
there's a purity of experience
especially when it comes to good coffee
that's why when you go to a place like
intelligentsia and they've got like a
you know eight dollar
pour over coffee and you ask for cream
in it
they look at you with disdain because
they're like you're not
you're actually taking you're not woke
yeah well you're not getting the
experience that
was intended by the person who made this
coffee
you're taking the edge off of something
that doesn't need the edge off this
isn't folgers so i respect
that but i also feel like
if you like cream in your coffee more
than you like black coffee
that trumps this prog if you're not
there yet or you don't want to go there
listen i tried for like a year to do
black coffee
and i was it was it was multi you know i
had multiple motivations
one was like okay it's more healthy
because there's no no there's less
calories in there if it's just coffee
yeah but also it's more badass
but then i just came to the conclusion
i'm not going to try anymore and then
during the
pandemic i've become what i would call
a cafe olay man i mean i'm basically
you got that extra time to whip it up
i'm just saying
that i'm about fifty percent milk fifty
percent of coffee if i can be
and you know what i love everything
about it
so you so you changed your mind and i
thought i had too
but i i clearly haven't fully changed my
mind
to accept my preference and not judge
myself
i think that you know there seems to be
a tinge of pride in her post
it's important to assert dominance over
beverages well i think what she is doing
might have been baiting you because i
think this is something
no i you listen she's obviously saying
something
slightly tongue-in-cheek uh but i think
it is reflective
of that sort of cultural expectation of
drinking black coffee being more
respectable which incidentally
we've paired this with another question
well in but
i'm sorry before you do i did want to
acknowledge that like when i was
thinking of the ways that i've changed
my mind over the years
like i made a decision to start drinking
coffee
in college because it's like what am i
missing and yeah
you know is this going to be is this
going to be helpful to keep me awake and
you know so i actually i changed my mind
about coffee
you felt like you were coming out so me
we both started drinking coffee in
college and i think
many people do because you're becoming
an independent adult and you're like
this is what adults do
it's the same reason a lot of people
start drinking alcohol and don't like it
at first
i don't think that that social pressure
is all bad or even bad at all i think
it's just a natural part of life and you
actually
sometimes social pressure to mature and
become an adult
and actually go through the process of
acquiring a taste there's some people
who are like
okay the whole acquired taste thing is
just [ __ ] because what you guys are
saying is that you don't really like it
but you're making yourself like it so
i'm never going down that
but there's a reward at the end of an
acquired taste
journey yeah someone else made a post
right about uh
whiskey exactly it's a super common
process
i don't think that's all bad but there
is a negative element to it which you're
kind of getting at with the
judging yourself in the midst of the
process right
and that's where i think that uh arsha
mythical zanskaz on twitter
is kind of tapped into something and
this is what they have changed their
behavior about
a change their mind about my behavior
i'm a textbook people pleaser a very
anxious person
and have abandonment issues all my life
i've tried never to say no to someone
try to fit into social norms and be the
ideal person
now after therapy i prioritize myself
and my mental health thank you for
sharing this
archea or shia this is
by far the most common response that we
got to our particular post was
you know related to the topic of um
another way to put it is realizing that
you're
your life is your own and if you start
to
trace the motives behind the decisions
you're making
if if if you start pulling on those
strings
and they go out to other people or to
just
other ideas outside of yourself i
i think it it can it can lead to
problems
right well it is an interesting balance
right
because i do believe that social
pressure in general there's a reason
that social pressure
exists and there's a positive reason
right we are
a collective organism whether we like it
or not and whether facebook seems to
reflect that or not
we are members of a community we're
members of a collective and there's a
lot of
aspects of our uh our personalities and
our biology
that are kind of tuned towards us
getting along in the context of a group
that's where like the concept
concept of shame like the concept of
shame
is not intrinsically bad
from a biological perspective it comes
from something that was actually useful
but
yeah but in the modern world it's mostly
toxic in the way that we experience it
right and apply
it i mean yeah so it it does bear saying
that there there are certain things that
no one should get away with just because
it's their
prerogative right there's there's a
right there's a whole litany of those
things
yeah but there are you know if you
if you know if you're a if you're a
a well-meaning person with a certain
level of
humility that you know starts to
understand themselves like
uh this person's saying uh through
therapy
and understanding that you've
de-prioritized yourself
to the point that um
the fact that it's it's your life is not
entering the
decision matrix right because when you
make decisions that
are about your health prioritizing your
mental health making you a better person
you actually become a better member of
the collective and you can so
you can it's a win-win situation when
you when you understand yourself right
and so i definitely listen i so relate
to this uh especially the i mean the
part about
you know being a people pleaser there's
things that i continue to unpack
unpack in therapy about just you know my
um my personality and why my personality
is what it is but i am a people pleaser
it's difficult to say no i do have this
sort of
idea of what is this is expected of me
and also a lot of times i evaluate the
things that i'm doing
in the context of how i will be
perceived about them and i have to
continually catch myself
doing that and then be like hold on are
you doing this
you're doing this for a bad sort of like
social reason so you
you'll be accepted or people will
perceive you in a certain way are you
actually thinking about yourself and
what you actually
like or what would be good for you you
don't want to prioritize yourself
selfishly so that then it takes
advantage of people because that's a
whole different that's a completely
different concept right
this is just about
realizing when you don't need to be
making a decision
because someone else's preference or
someone else's perception is the thing
that's driving you primarily
yeah you can become enslaved to other
people's expectations and opinions yeah
and you can die inside yeah
um and but realizing that opens the door
to
to changing your mind you know it's you
know i
going back to the beginning you know i
think about the phrase
of it's like when if somebody says
something that makes you change your
mind
i was thinking about the phrase if you
were to say back to them you changed my
mind
and just the idea that well
you know sometimes you can you can you
can realize that your mind has changed
you can realize that someone has had an
influence over you and that it could be
a true statement
you changed my mind but it seems like
the more healthy disposition
and approach is to say you know what i
am the one who changes my mind i can
choose
whether i allow someone's influence or
you know not just a person an experience
whatever the case may be
to to influence me but it's you know
giving someone the power it's giving
somebody power over you
if you're saying you know and maybe it's
semantics but saying you changed my mind
versus i think it's important you you
helped me change my mind
yeah but but i'm but but i'm in charge
again this is
this is this is my life the decisions
that i make the perspectives that i have
the actions that i take
you know i'm ultimately culpable for
those you just can't say well somebody
told me to do it well therapy is a
perfect example right like that's why
good therapists and most therapists
don't
give advice and they don't tell you what
you should think they ask questions and
they lead you through a process of
self-discovery
because they understand that first of
all it ain't going to last if it's not a
personal
motivated change and second of all it's
like they don't have the power to do it
like you don't really have the power to
change someone's mind
and this is coming from a person who
tries to be persuasive
has a very sort of i'm out to change
people's minds
natural disposition that i have to kind
of keep in check
just reminding myself that people don't
change their mind because of those kind
of things
now before we move on when we do we have
a short break in a second
but i do just want a related thing just
because i was thinking about we were
talking about shame and like
changing people's minds and social media
and all that stuff is bernay brown i was
listening to her recently
and she was talking about how shame is
not
a good tool
for social change
in other words the way to get
someone to realize that what they think
is wrong
if that's what your goal is shame is not
a great motivator it actually doesn't do
a lot to
change people's minds it just makes them
feel shameful which then kind of
shame usually leads to worse behavior
not like actual change
and good behavior but it seems that
that's something that happens on both
sides of the and i don't like to do the
whole both sides thing but
um one of the things i've observed like
as our country has gotten
even more polarized this year than it
ever was
in a time when it seemed like we had a
great opportunity to kind of come
together we got more polarized
both sides tend to point out things
about the other side
mischaracterize things about the other
side and in the process
the goal is like i'm shaming you because
you think this or
you believe this or you've identified in
this way
and that is shameful it might be true
that it's shameful there are behaviors
that are shameful there are things that
you can say and do and things that you
can believe that are truly shameful
but shaming someone about them doesn't
tend to be a great way to change their
minds about them
just a just a sidebar there
uh we got more questions but we also
have um
a pop socket to tell you about we got
multiple pop sockets but the one that we
uh
is your phone falling off your hand well
you need a pop socket
this one has the gmm logo available at
mythical.com
there's also like a feel-good mythical
morning yeah there is
and another one maybe a mythical one
are you looking for another way to
fidget with your phone
you're gonna want one of these a
mythical pop socket
available at mythical.com oh yeah
pop it sock it pop it
no this is not a bop it ad i like this
one jade marie posted
i used to say that i hated all country
music
when i really just hated the uncle who
would always listen to country music
no one wanted to hear that opinion
though yeah again
we did this is the case this is a case
of
your perception on your perspective of
something
is influenced by a relationship in a
negative way
yeah i get it i mean didn't you but then
you realize you're making a decision you
told me a story you may have told
them this story about how you made a
decision to
not like music because your stepsister
liked music yeah when i was like in
grade school
i don't know it's you know there was
just
it's not that we hated each other but
there was a step sister stepsister there
was this implied
i mean we would argue we had to share a
bathroom uh
you know i didn't uh
let's see she was probably you know
she's like a teenager
six you know maybe five years older than
me you know and she
she was she was not she was just she was
just acting on teenage instinct when
they were thrust into each other's lives
at a really interesting time
right yeah so i was like you know what
i'm not going to like anything that she
likes
including music yeah yeah it wasn't a
genre it was just like
music as a thing so there was definitely
i'm sure that that was a statement i
don't like music
i mean now music is one of my
my top passions right um but
there so there was a point when it was
like
uh i think once we started once i
started going over to friends homes and
like
oh like they're really enjoying music i
got to change my mind about this or i'm
going to be
i'm i'm a check out of the zeitgeist i
think that those are the terms i used as
a third grader that's that
know it's like uh man i gotta i gotta
get this new tape i gotta i gotta start
listening to tapes
well and specifically i changed my mind
i'm proud to say
i do like music now a lot of people
don't like country music
because of the association and you know
what
whatever you associate that with right
if it's the parts about the south that
embarrass you
uh which there are parts about
everywhere that embarrass everyone who's
from them
uh and if it feels maybe it's just a
twangy earnestness of it
but but i'm saying that it represents or
is associated with the distillation of
the things that embarrass you about a
place
there's a lot of people we grew up with
a lot of people who are like
i'm don't i think that country music
isn't sophisticated so i'm going to not
like it
and it and sometimes you don't even give
you don't even give it a chance now i
will say
i went through a fate now we always
liked country music but we always
liked sort of classic country music and
there were a few sort of modern artists
like i went i was
really into garth brooks in the early
90s
i did not follow him into the chris
gaines era
okay i'm proud to say that i didn't do
that not because it wasn't country just
because it was horrible
but um i think that and then as an adult
like even like right after jesse and i
got married we went through a couple of
years phase
where we would listen to like 94.7 in
raleigh like the
modern modern country and it was
so positive and so sweet that there was
this sort of like young love
married starting a family kind of vibe
that country music sort of
yeah just unironically embraces that we
liked
um now when we go back to i don't listen
to much modern country at all right now
yeah uh i mean i love jason isabelle and
churchill simpson
but they kind of are kind of they don't
really they're not considering that
they aren't considered country by a lot
of the country people
but when we go back to north carolina
one of the things that i do
as a habit is we listen to local country
radio
whenever we drive in the car just to
like
kind of just dip in completely and it's
it's difficult for me to take i got to
be honest yeah pretty difficult
but like eradicating and writing off an
entire
genre of all country music uh or
you know someone made the same post but
about electronic music and then started
described how they unders began to
understand the craftsmanship around it
and they changed their mind about the
well true music has to be has to be
created with
actual like acoustic instruments
yeah or you know like playable
instruments and even that
even that i don't know they say the
dichotomy a little bit dichotomy a
little bit differently because you would
yeah boomer perspective
like the way boomers think about rap
like you know i've heard
many boomers talk about rap as if rap
doesn't take any talent right like oh
these guys are just standing there and
like
you go see them in concert there's just
music playing and they're walking around
right i think we have an appreciation
for it because
we've tried to do it in parody form you
know
yeah we've we've tried to be like all
right we're going to do this rap
and when you recognize how
hard it is to make it sound good or make
it sound anywhere close to what a
professional would do you start
realizing that
this is the same thing with like i've
always had this thing about poetry
which is like okay so
what what's the deal with poetry yeah
especially poetry that doesn't rhyme
somebody
you know what i mean it's just yeah it's
like it's yeah
it's just there's a couple of smattering
of words
and then and a random invention and then
another smattering of words
but i've lived like it's over i've lived
long enough
to know that if i were really to dive
into the world of poetry
i would be like i see what makes a good
poet i gotta say i'm
i'm i'm an unsophisticated country boy
from north carolina in a lot of ways and
one of those ways is that my favorite
poet is shel
silverstein right yeah happy to say it
um but i'm sure that if i understood
like
the reality of what makes emily
dickinson good
that i would be like oh this isn't this
isn't just something that somebody
determined like there's a
there's actually a reason for this and i
couldn't do it i couldn't just start
writing things
everybody thinks that they're they can
write poetry right yeah
but that's not how it works it's more
complex
um i think that's all i have to say
about country music
john muller uh gets you know
gets really honest here in fact begins
the post with honestly y'all
dot dot dot um the way
he changed his mind was related to black
lives matter he says honestly y'all
black lives matter i was one of those
dumb people who got mad at
copernic kaepernick how i say that
when i see it i'm like i'm going to say
it wrong yeah well you did kaepernick
about his protest but what happened
throughout last year really galvanized a
180 degree change for me hat tip to
michael shay
matters and dave chappelle as well
yeah again thanks john for sharing that
yeah thanks for being honest and
vulnerable
you know publicly it's not something
that happens a lot especially
you know you don't hear it a whole lot
from uh
white guys who say y'all you know that
this is something that they change their
minds about
so thanks for doing that i think that uh
you know
we feel like we can speak with some
authority on this issue because
we are white boys who grew up in the
south and
uh had perspective on these things
that uh we don't think was really based
in reality and
was ultimately could ultimately be
described as racist right
not in your classic
external explicit expressions of racism
that you'd see in like a movie about the
deep south
but more of this this is something that
is in
the fabric of the way that we think and
we see the world that ultimately is
rooted in
this idea that whiteness is the standard
and whiteness is normal
and it you know it's taken years to to
deconstruct
deconstruct that and to see all the
places that it impacted and all the ways
that it impacted our thinking
i mean i talked a little bit about this
in my letter to a white man uh
that i wrote well a lot about it that
was the point of yeah that was the point
was to talk to my former self but the
the i mean in general when you say i
changed my mind about blank but then
specifically
if it's i change my mind about
um systemic racism uh
and or the black lives matter movement
that
you know that's that's a loaded
statement
right because it implies that you're
coming from a place that
is is is rooted in uh the opposite
rooted in
as you just said like uh in racism
yeah if you trade if maybe it's not on
the surface but if you trace it back
you you have those tendencies and it's
it's
it's been baked into your your psyche
and you've got to
scrape it out yeah and it's also over
time so but there's a con so there's a
confession in there
for real yeah you know so that's why i i
applaud
john john whenever you whenever you say
you change your mind about something
there's all
there is it's that level of humility to
say
especially on this topic that like
i was wrong about one of the you know
one of the things that like
you know if you could just say i adopt
yes i i support black lives matter and
you just say only the positive
you know maybe that's great
but to say i'm coming to grips with
what i used to believe and i'm changing
is
i think that humility has called for it
for um
it it has so much more of an impact on
on others as well it's much more
powerful i mean
listen the reason i
put that article i i wrote that article
in that way for two reasons one is i
wasn't trying to be like hey i'm an
authority on this
it was more like my primary goal this
year as it relates to these issues is
just
to listen and learn because i don't i'm
not as well educated and i don't have
the personal experience
of people of color and what they've gone
through
but the second thing was this is the
only thing that
might have been uh meaningful and
impactful to me in the past is just
hearing someone
that i could relate to talk about these
things right and that's why i kind of
wrote this letter to my former self
um but this is a this is a really
difficult thing to change your mind on
especially when you've got
lots of people in your community and in
the world frankly
who find all kinds of ways to discredit
the movement right so it might be
anything from like okay well let me tell
you what black lives matter did black
lives matter
was responsible for violent you know
riots or
however you want to you know so saying
that there because there was
violence or that property damage or
whatever that took place as
in conjunction with the the blm protest
therefore
the underlying thing that's being fought
for is illegitimate and you can just
write the whole thing off
or you can mischaracterize the movement
as
this is just a marxist movement that's
designed to
completely rip apart the fabric of
traditional america and therefore i'm
going to again
write off i'm not going to entertain any
empathy for this and i'm not going to
try to address the central issue that's
being that's being talked about
there's so many sort of corners that you
can crawl into to avoid
actually dealing with the central issue
of the history of systemic racism and
the way that it is morphed and changed
and gotten
even more sort of conniving uh in more
in the more recent past and not as
obvious which makes it even harder to
sniff out
but it just honestly
it takes a lot it takes a lot for people
to
experience this kind of change uh and we
personally have a lot of empathy
for the people who uh are resistant to
that change
and are experiencing that change so you
know again
like link said kudos to john for for
sharing this because
it's really the only way that we can see
real changes is the people who
are holding back the change are actually
experiencing the change
and i and i just think that it's
it's it's powerful it just bears saying
again because it's you know it might be
easy for us just to say
all the all the positive things and to
say the right things
about the black lives matter movement
now because
we are in front of these microphones and
you could argue that we have
some we have something to lose by saying
the
the wrong thing yeah i hope you know
that's not what's going on and that
we're
you know we're sincere about this but
part of that is saying we've had to
change
you know i think that's kind of the
proof in it is saying well it's not that
i've always been on the right side of
this i've been
i was you know i grew up on the wrong
side of this yeah
um and so making that change is nothing
to
nothing to brag about it's something
that instinctively i'd rather not talk
about
yeah but again that's why in general
today we're
we we're championing people who say i
changed my mind
yeah um yeah which implies
that like like john was saying that
180 degree turn well and i think it's
significant
that you know he points out michael shea
and dave chappelle right
and you know both of those guys tend to
be pretty polarizing figures in their
own right right
you take dave chappelle dave chappelle
says a lot of things that are offensive
to a lot of people
uh he tends to be a very polarizing
character um but i find it interesting
that somebody like john
would say well you know dave chappelle
was actually responsible
partially responsible for me changing my
mind about this central issue
and i think again that goes to that this
is not some clean
process there's not just this you know
everybody who thinks right about this is
on this side everybody thinks wrong
about it is on this side
and you have to be you have to talk
about this stuff and you have to be
right in the every single way that you
talk about it
and you have to be super super
consistent
when when we insist on this absolute
standard of excellence and complete
wokeness
in order to accept people one of the
things that we do is we
we lose the ultimate mission which is
not that we all just think exactly the
same way and agree on every single thing
and have some standard that we hold
ourselves accountable to
no we've got a whole lot of people that
we're trying to move in the right
direction
the goal is for all of us to
collectively get better and that right
in that you have to take into account
process right
and i think efficacy and i think people
like james i think honestly
i'm not saying again me saying that i
think dave chappelle has been a force
for good in this particular regard as
john is pointing out
does not mean that i endorse all of dave
chappelle's comedy or
all dave chappelle's uh perspectives
but all i'm saying is that i don't have
to
agree with every single thing that
somebody does or says in order to be
able to say that they've been a force
for good about this particular issue and
be like you know what
you did some good work there and that's
great you change somebody's mind
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to change
people's mind we're trying to like you
said become better as a collective
we're not just trying to be like here's
the fence between the two sides
and i want to make sure that i keep
putting up boards on that fence and make
sure everybody's over here on this side
and let's keep building that fence
higher and higher and higher no what we
want to do is we want to bring the fence
down lower and lower and continue to
bring people over it
i would much rather be friends with
someone who
was um
not on the right side of an issue but
demonstrated a sincere
open mind to it yeah than someone
who believed all the right things
and was firmly in the right
if you know if you're able to assess
that by
from any vantage point you know it's
just that that's not
there's there's no grace that's not a
reflection of
humanity and how you know the ex
the the human experience of
you know everybody somewhere and is not
going to be right about every
everything and they're not going to be
wrong about most things and you're going
to be wrong about most things
everyone is going to be wrong about most
things it's it's easy to put it in the
poetry
example again you know if someone said
you know i don't
i don't get poetry it's like you know
what and if i was a poetry scholar
let's say it could have been or let's
say that's what i was most passionate
about
it's not actually you have glasses i'm
with you i don't get poetry
uh but i just wouldn't
i don't know that i would want to
converse with someone who say i
you know i hate poetry right you know
it's just
versus i don't really i don't think i
understand poetry
jazz i don't think i understand poetry
enough to really appreciate it
that's one way to say it you know what i
mean and so yeah and again
i think that we talk about we talk about
these things in a way that
maybe again it's it's if
what i am saying is that i have empathy
for people who disagree with me
because i disagree with my past self
right
it's as simple as that and
i don't know i get so frustrated with
the nature of dialogue
on both the left and the right because
it's as if
the goal is to solidify
the ranks versus actually make progress
and move the collective in the right
direction and i don't know i just feel
like
um because we get into a place where
it's just like oh that person said
this thing that offended me and
therefore every single thing they've
ever done or will ever do
is illegitimate it's like well i
i i'm i don't want to treat myself in
that way i don't want to treat anybody
in that way i wouldn't want to be
treated that way
because i'm going to be wrong i'm going
to say things that are wrong i have said
things that are wrong
i'll tell you something i was wrong
about and it's this next one okay
just to get just to lighten it up a
little bit rachel said i insisted
we would never have pets inside the
house
then we got our cat and i insisted she'd
never be allowed in the bedroom but now
both our cats sleep in the bed and i
would kill a man
if either of them requested it oh wow
kill a man if the cats requested it talk
about a a reframing of allegiance but
i mean yeah for for years i was like you
know i
i am not going to have pets in the house
i am not
you know that's not who we are and then
i came up with other reasons to tell the
kids why it wasn't going to happen
but like i just you know i didn't like
the idea of hair
i didn't like the idea of the of the
poop even if the poop was outside
i mean you don't want poop on the
perimeter every single
time i'm just you know doting over
jade or babying her you know the kids
still love to point out like
aren't you glad that you were wrong
about that and i was like
i i you know what and it's an
opportunity for me to say you know i'm
kids i'm glad that that you forced this
issue
lily in particular with with the dog
uh i'm gonna save any conversation about
the cat that does
live in our home to for for
a subsequent thing yeah i will
acknowledge that there's we now have
a dog and a cat animal living inside of
our house
um but i try to acknowledge yeah i take
those moments to be like yeah i'm i'm
grateful
that i have done a complete 180. like my
life is so enriched and then i'll just
start gushing about jade but
really i see it as an opportunity to
in an innocuous way on an innocuous
topic
to say i would you know what i changed
my mind
i did change my perspective it wasn't
about being right or being wrong it's
not more
about morality here but it's about
humility of saying you know what i did
change my mind and
uh i disagree with my former self and
uh my my life is better
because i because i changed than than it
was before
and don't you think that's really the
heart of it is the fact that
when you didn't have animals in the
house the only thing that you had to go
on was the perceived negative aspects of
having animals in the house right it's
like you can't really
perceive positives without experiencing
them but you can kind of
anticipate negatives it's much easier i
don't know why it's just where our
brains work
but then when you begin to experience
the love that you can have for
a dog which started you know and and and
a love that wasn't the same kind of love
that like we had for our dogs growing up
that like were like
out in the shed in the back kind of
thing you know they were more like
we had just had like a wolf that we
happened to round up
no inside the house dog that like you
received this physical
love from on a regular basis like
your standards will begin to change very
quickly because you see the other side
of the coin
right and then you're like oh there are
going to be some inconveniences i mean
one of the things that i think about and
we've talked about this is when you
decide to
love something then you start thinking
about the fact that this thing
is not this thing doesn't live as long
as me like
this dog will die most likely before i
will right if we both live to our
general life expectancy i'm going to
outlive barbara
and now i think about dang that's going
to be really difficult
but i'm still willing to make the
sacrifice because of the positive that
i'm experiencing right now
it's really about and and to if you try
to take that
and map it on to something that is more
moral
or you know
i don't exactly know how you do that
like how do you get someone to
i think it goes back to what you said
which is you got to make the experience
personal right it's not something that
you're just gonna you can't just sit
and think about the idea of a dog
in your house in your head and come to
some conclusion to be like i love dogs
in my house
it's like you got to have a dog in the
house you know you got to have a friend
who challenges your perspective you got
to see some something
in some you have to have a personal
experience in order to to change your
mind about something
ultimately right and your personal
experience is with having a dog in the
house and now a cat in the house
and and i'd much rather convey that
principle to my kids
than having all the answers or
or being right it's it's being willing
to be
to admit when you're wrong or when
you've changed your mind on something
that's not about right or wrong
even yeah is more important than than
than being right at any particular
moment
you know it's cause think about how
miserable you'd be if the only thing you
were doing was focusing on
continuing to bolster your predetermined
argument that having animals in the
house was bad i can imagine
that there are dads out there moms
brothers sisters who i was dead
set against having a dog in the house
and now that there's a dog in the house
i'm the person who doesn't like it and i
spend all my time pointing out all the
things that the dog is doing that are
bad like what a miserable existence
versus accepting it and yeah because
then you're like secretly petting the
dog
you know what you don't want to you
don't want to be seen right you have a
secret relationship and then that gets
weird
you know right secret putting well i
you know what the there's there's other
there's other ones but we're not going
to get to them
for the sake of time but we'll do this
again but
the fact that we did have such great
responses
and we still want to continue to
encourage people to respond
and you know one of the things that we
were talking about that i want to talk
to them about i want to talk to you
about is
if you've never responded to a prompt on
your biscuits maybe that's because
you don't follow us on twitter or
you're not the type of person to to
respond to just
open-ended questions associated with
this show on the internet
or on the internet in general but we
want to invite you to take a risk and do
that
so uh you fi if you follow
our app mythical twitter account or our
personal accounts we can try to do a
better job of of retweeting those
prompts
as well but if you definitely if you
follow the app mythical account
you can see every so often uh when we
post these prompts like this one about
uh tell us about when you change your
mind we just want to hear from
for more of you we enjoy the familiar
faces and the familiar names and
uh you really get that sense of
community and uh
so we're not complaining about that but
we do think there's a whole group of
people who
um just kind of watching you know you i
bet you're a thoughtful lurker
yeah and we want to hear from you on
these on these topics and sometimes
sometimes the questions are tough it
might take a little a little time to
think about it
but you don't have to answer immediately
you can come back and we usually give
you know at least a day where you can
come back and add to it before we roll
everything up but
yeah i mean like link said we definitely
appreciate uh
the folks who always respond to the
prompts uh
but we are you know really interested in
hearing from people who've never
responded who might say i created a
twitter account just so i could respond
so
hashtag gearbiscuits uh we you can
continue to talk about what we talked
about today but also be looking for that
next prompt that we're going to put out
there to get your
questions and now i'm going to give my
wreck
give us my week um
on disney plus there's
there you know you can search by all the
different
brands that they own like marvel and
star wars and
it goes on from there and you know i
they're doing a lot of things where
they're creating content
around content like behind the scenes
series for the mandalorian series which
is
absolutely amazing um so i got curious
and i was looking around there's there's
lots of that
in marvel the marvel section as well
but there's one um show called marvel
616.
and it's basically this concept of
taking
principles around the marvel properties
and just exploring
these like tertiary ideas or behind the
scenes
type things they're all each episode is
completely different and i've only
watched one so i'm only
uh recommending episode one
which is about the japanese spider-man
now i have i've had a t-shirt for years
that had spider-man and then it had
japanese writing underneath it
and i just thought it was a cool t-shirt
well
it turns out there's a
in marvel licensed spider-man
over in japan to and then they created
a television show for spider-man and
it was entirely different it
it was you know there was some emissary
who pitched it to marvel and then
this it's a documentary on creating an
alternate
universe basically a japanese version of
spider-man
that is totally totally different we
have a suit he looks the same
it's the same suit but he's
the action adventurer that he's in like
it's not it's not peter parker
well that makes sense right and he's not
in new york
but i mean like he fights robots he he
like drives vehicles
he still behaves like a spider
and but the and they talk about like how
they made the show and it's just
absolutely fascinating just a one-off
documentary it's a it's a one-off just
that one the one episode
um and you know it's it's
the all of the people who were involved
in it
they even talked to the stuntmen who
were like they did
there's this iconic tower in tokyo
i think it's called tokyo tower i'm
probably getting all this wrong
but that's a good guess well i mean they
tell the story of him showing up
the stuntman showing up on one of his
first days and he puts on the spider-man
costume and then they just tell him okay
he's just showing up for work to be
spider-man and they're like
climb the tower with no net no
no safety mechanisms he free climbs this
tower and then they use that shot
in like the closing or opening credits
of the show i mean you want to get your
money's worth if someone's going to put
their life on the line
but all the stuff this guy would do like
they would they didn't have any budget
but they would it was important that
they
were like high action what years are we
talking about
this is the 70s and like so he would
fight these gigantic robots because you
had to have gigantic robots
in uh japanese shows
right that's what that's what all of
them were right so
it's at every turn in everything they do
it's just
splendidly strange to us as americans
who know our spider-man
but because you know they were able to
separate things and there was no
internet and like
they didn't share shows and marvel said
do whatever you want with spider-man and
make it work over here in japan
but it can't leave japan right it could
be contained at the time and it could be
contained
and so now if you if you watch these
clips it's just
like bonkers to us but and the stories
are equally bonkers so
i would definitely recommend that marvel
616 episode one
episode one maybe you'll watch episode
two thanks for joining us
hashtag here biscuits to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best